Wozu gehen Teenager in die Tanzschule?
Ja gut, um tanzen zu lernen,
aber wohl auch, um sich näher zu kommen.
Und genau das geht gerade nicht.
Bitte nicht übertreten!
Tanzen ja, aber kontaktlos –
mit drei Metern Abstand.
Wie soll es da klappen zwischen Tänzer
und Tänzerin?
Ja, sie muss sehr viel mehr wissen,
also auswendig lernen,
damit sie auch das macht, was ich will.
Ich finde, man kann viel besser an sich
arbeiten, einfach an den Techniken und so.
Man hat keinen Partner, der einem
irgendwie noch andere Sachen zeigt
oder irgendwie noch andere Einflüsse gibt.
Die Solotänzer machen das Beste
aus der Situation.
Aber von außen betrachtet wirkt der
Schattentanz dann doch etwas herzlos.
Mir macht Tanzen mit Partner mehr Spaß,
weil, man kann sich besser unterhalten,
man lernt sich auf ’ner anderen Ebene
noch mal kennen.
Drehen, drehen, drehen, drehen –
erst mal zum Fenster ...
Der Tanzlehrer ist überzeugt, dass auch die
reduzierte Form des Tanzes funktioniert,
wenigstens in den nächsten Wochen.
Die kennen sich, die lachen miteinander,
die schauen sich in die Augen,
da geht mal was schief,
dann lachen sie und haben Spaß.
Es ist genug Nähe da, also, und es ist ja nicht
… keine dauerhafte Lösung.
Das wissen die, das wissen wir,
und deswegen können wir das
jetzt mal so verschmerzen.
Der nächste Kurs und – oh Schreck:
ein enger Paartanz.
Sind jetzt etwa Corona-Rowdys am Start?
Im Gegenteil: Ehepaare, die sich schon
viele Jahre berühren.
Auch sie müssen allerdings auf die
Abstandsmarkierung achten,
dürfen aber tanzen wie gewohnt.
Ohne Tanz hatten wir echt Entzug!
Und wir tanzen seit zehn Jahren.
Es hat uns ganz doll gefehlt, ja,
und wir haben uns damit beholfen, doch in
unserer großen Diele doch aktiv zu sein.
Das Ziel des Trainings:
der Winterball, zu Weihnachten –
wenn er denn stattfinden darf.
Die Tanzschulen sind schon froh,
dass überhaupt wieder was los ist
auf ihrem Parkett,
nach fast drei Monaten Zwangspause.
Wir hatten zum Glück ganz,
ganz viele treue Kunden,
die uns über die Zeit gerettet haben,
die weiter ihre Beiträge bezahlt haben,
aber gerade große Umsätze
wie von Veranstaltungen,
wie unser Gastro-Umsatz,
und natürlich auch viele Kündigungen
alleine wegen der Angst,
die uns erreicht haben,
da hatten wir schon sehr große Einbußen.
Von Angst ist hier keine Rede mehr,
höchstens davor,
sich auf die Füße zu treten.
Ansonsten gilt das Motto:
Tanzen ist auch
in Krisenzeiten unverzichtbar.